hello folks let's get started off with
the webinar so all of us are here today
are to learn about the three steps to a
dream big data rule oh this webinar is
intended for our simply learn Hadoop
students so that they can easily
navigate the complicated world of big
data skills and roles and you know
achieve your career potential as you
know big letter is being used across
industries there are variety of
technologies that are being used there
are different kind of roles and you know
and it's an emerging field so there's a
lot of new updates and a lot of things
that only somebody with a lot of
industry experience and a lot of
Industry nova below so we requested our
big data influential raw lillian pearson
so that she could you know chart out the
whole big data scenario that various
domains that are there the various skill
sets that are required the various job
opportunities that are there so that you
can take an informed decision and plan
your carrier and achieve your true
potential so that you can get the set
yourself apart as as Big Data
professionals and achieve the best roles
and project order out there so we have
with us Lillian Pearson yo she's a
experienced big data scientist with more
than 14 years of work experience or she
is also the author of three very highly
referenced technical books or data
science for dummies Big Data Hadoop for
dummies and managing the Big Data
workflows she has spent the last decade
the training and consulting for large
organizations in the private sector such
as IBM dell intel and also numerous
government organizations right from say
the US Navy to the local government
level she is also the founder of data
mania it's her passion to
an evangelist for big data and also she
has so your data journalist and she has
shared her unique industry experience
and know-how with a lot of people and I
will be handing over the presentation to
Lillian Pearson thank you so much AJ hi
everyone thank you so much for joining
us welcome to three steps to a big
dinner all of your dreams happy
Wednesday I'm excited to be presenting
for you all today I'm today I'm going to
discuss i'm going to clarify what's
involved in becoming a big data
architect or engineer but there's
actually a lot more change presentation
just that so let's get started the first
thing i'm going to talk about today's
I'm going to introduce the topic and
what are the benefits and drawbacks of
establishing a career in Big Data after
that I'm going to go into the hoosier
wats of a big data rumor that is hiring
what positions are available and what's
required to fill those positions after
that I'll be taught me about the big
data architect and engineer career paths
and identifying the skill sets that are
involved in those and um follow that
with current salary trends for big data
roles how much are these skills really
worth we're going to end the session
today talking about the next steps you
can take to get started in your um I
guess you guys are already part of the
Big Data Hadoop developer course so it's
not get started since you're already on
your way but um what are the next steps
you can take an evolution of your of
your training corp I've aj already
introduced me but i'll just take a few
seconds to introduce myself i'm lillian
pearson i'm a data scientist a data
science educator and a data journalist
i'm also a professional engineer I
author of books I did data science for
dummies and big day big data Hadoop for
dummies I'm social influencer and a
brand evangelists in the big data space
and
I've actually it's been more than 14
years now I have experience working in
the fields between data science and
spatial data sets so anyway enough about
me let's get started on the webinar
we're going to talk first about the
benefits of the seminal career and big
data the most clear and obvious benefits
of establishing your career in big data
is the high level of demand for these
type of professionals and behind
salaries but it's really good to
consider also the work environment for
most big data professionals is quite
friendly and happy the companies that
are hiring really want to keep the stuff
that they have because of the demand is
so high so they have a lot of
flexibility I'm allowing people to work
from home and when you're working in the
office just you know really cool
laid-back policies about a tire and get
sort of things pizza parties all that so
it's it's a good work environment also
you will enjoy the benefit of having a
prestigious position because like I said
that the demand is high and in a supply
at these type of professionals is so low
that um did data analytics and in big
data engineers and architects have a lot
of prestige within an organization also
what I really like is that the work can
be applied to all industries so whatever
your passion is you can find an
opportunity um within that industry with
um and if you look at the work on a
broader picture you're doing decision
support so it's pretty meaningful
because you're helping affect change
that would otherwise not be possible if
you weren't present so nope it's
meaningful work those are the benefits
of a clear and big data so drawback is
that of course Turks really technical so
you have to spend a lot of time and
effort I'm getting trained and then
there's a lot of responsibility there's
not going to be a lot of people you can
turn to to help you get the job done so
people are going to be leaking
you to perform and to get things right
the first time and since there's there's
in there's undersupply professionals
that can work in this capacity you're
going to be lucky if you have a good
support staff and you're probably going
to be having to do a lot of work get a
lot accomplished on your own and doing
the job of your dreams that might
require a relocation but I'm going to
talk about some jobs in India and also
jobs in the United States during this
webinar the last the last drawback is
that a lot of the companies a lot of the
bigger companies are wanting it several
years of experience so overcoming the
experience that I showed can be a
challenge but not necessarily so okay
now that you have a realistic picture of
the career field let's talk about the
tools and what's of a big data career
who's hiring what positions are
available and what's required to fill
those positions it's already narrow in
on the big data architect and engineer
rules I want to at least give you a
little information about the Big Data
industry at large although it's not a
cop oh this is not a comprehensive list
of all the roles in the space at least
give you an idea of what's happening so
I broke it up um main roles and big data
space to Dante big data data science and
data visualization so for those of you
in the Big Data career path and the
rules that you're most likely to get
when you Muniz finish would be a big
data architect or a big data engineer
sedating scientists may work is dead
scientist or data analytics engineers
and the data visualization professionals
usually get jobs as data visualization
developments so that's these are the
roles that I'm going to be talking about
today in this section starting first
with the data visualization developer
all the purpose of these are these type
of professionals is to build data
showcasing analytical individual
monitoring tools
and to develop data visualization
solutions and most of the most of the
the job advertisements out there asking
for at least a bachelor's degree and of
course skills in HTML Javascript III in
pendle X as far as companies that are
hiring on data visualization developers
there's en IBM and the weather company
are actually hiring for a data
visualization developers right now but
honestly there are less positions
available for people with in the
specialty turning out to data scientist
in the data analytics engineer rule the
purpose of this type of position of
people working the purpose behind this
job is to build algorithmic models for
detecting patterns in or responding to
high-volume real-time big data and these
type of professionals are building
decision support applications for
analyzing visualizing and modeling big
data to make better predictions and
drive better results most of the
position descriptions out there are now
asking for a masters masters degree plus
and of course skills and Python our
sequel statistics machine learning and
um of course is a strong subject matter
expertise right now the following
companies are hiring for a data
scientist there's an undersupply of data
scientist as well as data engineer so
all right now you need get a job with
indeed into it under armour and facebook
monsanto or birch works now that you've
gotten just a brief look at other roles
within the big data space i want to
focus more in on the big data architect
and engineer role the purpose of these
two work these type of professionals do
is to source acquire collect store
process integrate prepare and perform
simple analysis on massive data sets as
far as the skills and education that are
required
position descriptions of most of job ads
out there asking for a bachelor's degree
or higher training um and and hire
training as well as skills and hadoop
mapreduce calais park no sequel Java
Python among others the the squid skill
requirement isn't limited to that list
but you could expect these to see these
requirements in the end a job app for
husbands companies that are hiring for
big data architects and engineers could
amazon IBM dish network yum in oracle i
want to take a moment now just to take
you on a little interesting detour
there's many times i've seen ads for
positions or companies are hiring for
so-and-so engineer or so-and-so
developer but then the position
description looks almost identical
that's hard to tell the difference
between those titles so I did a little
research and I found a survey by
o'reilly from 2013 it really clarified
the differences between engineer
architect and developer titles in the
big data space survey respondents with
the title architect reported using more
d3 Java Hortonworks and Cassandra and
they reported spending more time on etl
and meeting attendance compared to
developers and engineers the developers
reported using using our programming
language less and using javascript in d3
more and they they reported it sounds
like they were working Lauren stated
that division excuse me data
visualization developers lastly the
engineers reported using less our Excel
and SAS and more Scala and spark they
reported spending it was less likely to
spend time presenting analysis this
brings us to section 3 of today's
webinar so big data architect
engineer career paths identifying the
skills involved thinking back on what
we've learned so far big data architects
report spending more time using Java
Hortonworks and Cassandra I'm assuming
that the Java work is for programming
and Methodist and the big data engineers
are reporting spending more time working
at scholar and spark and mongodb just to
remind you guys the purpose of this
these types of roles is to source a
choir collect store process integrate
prepare and perform simple analysis on
massive data sets so what are the
stepping stones to Big Data role of your
dreams those are really mass mastering
gaining mastery and experience in the
skills that are required to to carry out
the job those skills include Hadoop in
MapReduce spark scala MongoDB cassandra
and then also a lot of the positions are
talking about wanting people that have
experienced an Impala storm and cough if
we're going into a more narrow a
discussion of these technologies and
skill set let's see how they all fit to
fit and flow together so i made this
schematic here um it's really simple but
it hopefully gets the point across you
can see here that at the base you've got
the data storage layer where you got
Hadoop the HDFS and MapReduce you've got
no sequel databases and also a proper
you can cool operating in the data
storage then above that you've got the
data processing layer and you're getting
there batch processing tools like
mapreduce or real-time processing tools
there that are either in memory
applications or no sequel applications
and then on top you've got the data
consumption layer which I've just
included all the analytics and data
science work within that later so what
sure where does he do fall fall within
the big picture of course it's going to
fall within the data storage layer with
HDFS I'm acting as the filesystem
storing data and MapReduce doing the
processing work so it's on the data
storage and data processing there now I
want to we're going to now take some
time to get a more in-depth look at all
these skills and technologies that go
into big data engineering and big data
architecture for each technology i'm
going to be sure to emphasize the basics
of what that technology does and how it
fits in the bigger picture picture of a
big data solution I'm sure you guys are
mostly all aware because you're already
enrolled in this course but Hadoop is an
open source framework for collecting
processing and storing big data it uses
the Hadoop HDFS to store massive volumes
of data and that produce for carrying
out large-scale batch processing cells I
want to have here that according to the
CIO website um research analyst research
analysis that carried out people with
Hadoop skills are earning 13.7 ah % %
more salary than just say I'll software
engineers Without lahood developer
skills so what Hadoop does they do
prayer works Taurus huge volumes of big
data on commodity servers across
clustered it also processes that data
using the MapReduce parallel processing
engine how do picton the the broader
picture of a Big Data technology system
the Hadoop framework acts as a data
storage and data processing application
it stores data in redundancy across
nodes on commodity servers it also uses
not produced to batch process huge
volumes of data okay now you've seen
where Hadoop and MapReduce fit in but
let's move on to some of the other types
of technology and maybe less so what
also we're up at first we're going to
talk about spark spark is an application
that fits in the data processing layer
it's an N memory application in real
time processing tour according to the
Apache spark website uh they've defense
spark as a fast and general engine for
large-scale data processing it allows
you to run programs up to a hundred
times faster than than MapReduce in
memory or ten times faster faster on
disk so when I think of spark for me I
think of real-time analytics from
streaming big data sources because
that's one thing you can do with apache
spark and as a data scientist that's the
most interesting purpose for spark in my
opinion but let's look what does wets
Burke Ducks spark is a general
processing engine that is used to carry
out a batch processing as well as
real-time processing ad-hoc data query
and even moving looking at where spark
fits in spark is a real-time data
processing application that's used to
process and analyze all varieties and
velocities affected the same CIO source
cited that spark and Scala skills can
get employees up to fifteen thousand
dollars more per year in earnings
turning now to no sequel it's on the
data processing rare as well as the data
storage lives isn't a database it's a
database application what no sequel
database system no sequel databases use
a variety database technologies to store
in our treat non-relational and
relational data there are four types of
medical data bits those are key value
stores graph databases document stores
and column stores where no sequel
databases within no sequel databases are
part of the data storage layer of a big
data system the used for storing and
quickly retrieving structured
semi-structured
unstructured paper we're going to talk
about MongoDB and Cassandra today those
are both types of no sequel databases
first we can't mongodb MongoDB is a
document oriented type of no sequel
database it uses dynamic schemas and
storage data and a model that is very
similar to that of JSON it's the most
popular type of document strong market
what it does MongoDB uses a dynamic
schema to store document files in a
flexible storage model the flexibility
of this model allows for rapid reduction
and advancement during development
MongoDB acts as both a data storage
application and a real-time data
retrieval application for document files
so that's the thing you want to remember
about mom MongoDB is that it's another
sequel database for document falls and
according to the M CIO website MongoDB
professionals are earning 16.5 percent
more salary then then the counterparts
looking at the Cassandra the Cassandra
solution cassandra is an open source
project and that second generation
distributed no sequel database it's the
best choice for higher availability and
scalability of the database according to
simply Lin and it's a very popular type
of key value store note sequel database
what Cassandra does Apache for strong
thunderstorms and manages large amounts
of key value pair data across the
cluster of commodity servers it acts as
both the data storage application and a
real-time data retrieval application for
key value bitter so when you when you
think of Cassandra you want to think of
Q value a key value store now we're
going to look at Apache Kafka that's
located on the data storage layer Apache
Kafka is an open source highly
distributed and fault-tolerant message
broker designed for accommodating
real-time
feeds it's written in Scala according to
simply learn it's the preferred
messaging platform for processing big
data in real time and fast processing
with real-time message feeds what Kafka
does caca is a publish-subscribe
messaging system that's used for
maintaining message feeds on a topic by
topic basis as a David storage
application conference Kafka replicates
and stories messages across several
nodes were built in fault tolerance and
where cough cough it's in it's a
distributed data storage platform that
accommodates require requirements
involved in real-time message data
processing next we're going to look at
another and memory application o'clock
Impala and it sits in the data
processing power it's a popular type of
massively parallel processing database
and you use it as a sequel engine to
bypass Matthews and query data directly
from HDFS what it does is it sits on top
of the HDFS and allows users to you see
cool to perform fast ad-hoc queries of
data that's stored stored there so
impala a lot of tenses nice play there
by scientists in order to get the data
out of the HDFS without having to
without having to work with MapReduce
where it fits in and pollen is an
in-memory data processing application
that sits on top of the HD us according
to the CIO source um you can expect
empower and flush as well Impala skills
are earning 16.5 percent more salary
than their counterparts and these things
now that you understand these skills and
technologies are it's time for me to
introduce you to the steps you can take
to help you get the Big Data position of
your dreams step one is to get trained
as a big data and Hadoop developer so
congratulations to all of you because
you've already you're already enrolled
and training for that and may have even
completed that first step so high
back for that the next step is to get
trained in spark Scala and mongodb and
then the third step would be to get
trained in Cassandra but if you really
want to optimize your return on
investment here you'll take an extra
step to hybridize your skill set so i
would add a step forward hybridize your
skill set by getting trained in apollo
storm and or Kafka names will get you
prepared so that for higher earning
positions in the market you'll see what
I mean in a minute but let's just start
by next looking at the current salary
trends for big data rules and then i'll
show you how these hybrid rules are
where people are earning most of most
the highest salaries section 4 we're at
section for now and this is where you're
going to discuss salary rules and truths
in the big data architecture in zoom
positions just to refresh your mind a
number the o'reilly data science salary
survey where big data architects
reported mostly using um that using more
of java and cassandra and morton works
and big data engineers were reporting
working the scallops park in MongoDB
let's see the demand this map shows the
demand or the number of positions open
for big data engineers in the united
states you can see that washington DC
actually has the highest number of
openings with 757 and then followed by
San Francisco and Seattle but there's
there's thousands of openings for big
data engineers in the United States at
this at this time and not to fret
because also in India there are a lot of
a lot of physicians even more openings
in India so for people with Hadoop
skills there are three hundred and two
thousand one hundred and ninety three
positions open for spark skills there's
1379 positions open for people with no
sequel skills to
2976 positions open you guys can read
this but the point is is that there's a
lot of opportunity for big data
engineers in India as well the source
for this information comes from indeed
indeed India look at how much money big
data engineers are earning in the United
States I want to emphasize here that
when you look at this ah these are big
data engineer positions but if you take
big data professionals for the full
spectrum of skills would have called
hybrid hybridization and they have even
higher earning potential dinner than
these numbers but you can see that um of
course in San Francisco big dead
engineers are making the most money at
about almost 140,000 dollars here and
then over in Washington DC where there's
more demand um they're earning slightly
less at 125 thousand dollars per year
and over in seattle where they also have
a lot of demand people are earning about
120 seventy thousand dollars per year I
looked into it come to the what I could
find about these annual salaries in
India it looks like pay scale has some
good data and um police provided some
information about the data analyst data
scientists on big data architect Wilson
did analysts are earning 441 thousand
rupees as an annual salary so the
scientists are earning 1.3 million
rupees is in data salad as a low salary
and big data architects earn just over
two million rupees per year and all this
hybrid roles where you can earn the real
big bucks and this is what I was talking
about these are the these are the big
data professionals that have mastered
both aspects of architecture and
engineering plus some
you can see that a professional with
skills on Hadoop kafka Cassandra spark
Scala and mongodb are earning up two
hundred and forty thousand dollars per
year but then of course the the demand
for these positions is lower so it was
about 101 jobcentre asking for all of
these skill sets I'll just take you
through a few more because you can look
and kind of see for yourself what you're
interested in but um Kafka Hadoop
Cassandra sparking MongoDB a position
that requires all of those skills 106 of
them and they're averaging out at
salaries of about one hundred and thirty
three thousand dollars per year and then
for people with skills in Hadoop
Cassandra spark and mongodb which are
what you will pick up just by following
the basic three steps that we laid out
for you they're earning a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars per year and
there's 195 positions currently
available within the United States all
of this data is coming from indeed com
so now you understand um what these
technologies and skill sets are and how
they integrate together to form a big
data solution we want to discuss with
you the next steps to take I'm going to
turn it over to AJ for that and then if
you have questions make sure to put them
in the question client so that I can get
to them and um and in our Q&A session
after your pool thanks ah Lillian that
was really enlightening webinar me I was
a very interesting takeaways I think all
of us can it from this session
especially about how multi stealing
having a bunch of big data scales can
greatly push up your career and at the
same time it was also very interesting
to understand where these areas Big Data
technologies fit in and how for
different kinds of roles you need to
develop a different kind of skill set so
so folks
with all these on sites i know you know
then the rod with the industry know-how
and insights we have actually developed
a big data Hadoop architect program so
this is intended for to provide the
skill set of a big data Hadoop architect
so as you can see all the skills that we
talked about which are required for the
Big Data Hadoop role and which ensure
that you get the best roles and the best
salaries are included in this not just
we have these in-depth full-length
courses which have projects practice
quizzes simulation exams and so on in
addition we also have expert mentoring
sessions so that you can regularly touch
base with our experts and as well as we
also have a very active forum where you
can any point of time talk to our
teaching assistants or our experts so
that they can help you I have worked
with either your carrier or with any
technical you know issues that you might
be having so this is a great program we
have abated after a lot of inputs from
industry experts are influencers a lot
of artistics and we hope you can not you
can use this to further the potential of
your carriers and as an exclusive
because for all the people who have
attended this webinar we have a coupon
code which is exclusive for us simply on
alumni as you can see you in to eat the
coupon code its masters webinar 40 it's
applicable for a week we hope you make
use of this oh okay good as a question
about um ok sorry I was just reading
some questions about titles beyond
developer so of course we've discussed
architect engineer developers but then
there's also going to be big data
scientists analysts and specialists I've
seen all of these types of titles and
then position descriptions and then just
loosely um so I felt pretty lucky to
have found that survey where people
actually responded and come
give a better definition of what of what
they're doing is engineers and
architects but for the most part when
you're looking at Java do you have to
kind of just decipher between them and
see which ones are most interesting to
you and the ones that your best
qualified so um someone asked to devote
yeah yeah Lillian are we have a question
from India needle here's a question
saying or how typically how long does it
gain or take to gain all these skill
sets so imagine if he is going for a big
Gator Hydra pocketed he wants to know
how much time will he take to achieve
this case it I think that depends on the
amount of time you have to invest in
your training they get how if you're if
you have a full-time position and you're
just working on a course work at night
then um been taking it a slow paced any
could spend two years doing something
like that but if you were working
steadily on getting trained and aunt
experience I don't want to um I don't
want to understate that that had the
importance of also getting experience um
I'd say six to nine months to get
through the series that that sibley
learn has laid out it also depends on
your background though because um
depending on the skill set to already
have and the programming what
programming languages you already know
it could take longer or it could take
less time I know just to add know from a
statistical perspective usually or the
full length courses that simply run has
we have seen that average learner is
usually take about two months to finish
of course and the shorter courses
usually if they take about three to five
weeks so that gives you an estimate of
how much time the whole skill set
political and neha linda has this
question that if i had to choose among
these skins I would
I prioritize them I know Hadoop but if I
have which is the next skill that I have
to be well okay so that goes back to the
free stuff the three-step process that
we discussed um just MongoDB sparking
Scala courses as step two and then take
Lucan Sondra courses step 3 and then I
would suggest taking some other courses
like in Impala a Kafka as well if you
really want to get yourself a better
position Lillian they have a question
from jyoti or she wants to know that she
is she says she's not from a developer
background but she has been working or
she has been in here a professional for
the last 15 years so she wants to know
how she can now you know or develop her
profile so that she can work and dictate
I she has IT experience then um I mean
she just needs to get trained and start
working on projects hey I don't know her
background um so I can't really say
exactly what she would specifically need
to do okay and I be chic girl has a
question oh so he's actually from a
quality assurance background he has
about ten years of experience he's got
his Hadoop certificate and he is a
little confused about which area to go
towards so he would watch my freaking
through some more light on that I think
that's kind of a personal question
because he needs to I mean I think that
this is sort of I thought that they were
going to talk to you about kind of
career guidance of like that comes on to
what his passion is and yeah so we'll
have somebody with marketed under 10
connect with abhishek so that we can
take up the matter personally and we
have a question from by sharat chandra
where he talks about he is asking what
is it
can you elaborate on the difference
between mongodb and Cassandra yeah so
both of them are no sequel databases but
[ __ ] TV is used as it's a document
story and cassandra is for a key value
pair data so that's the largest come in
the mail the most glaring difference
between them another question which is
more related to the data scientist so he
wants to know because we had to detail
on the big data architect role he wants
to know what I know skills I would you
recommend for being a data scientist in
the US so if you want to wear casa de
the scientist then you definitely need
to get change there are a Python and
sequel and then I don't think that I key
IT professionals make the best vested a
scientist because usually the subject
matter expertise isn't as specialized as
it needs to be to derive insights when
when the when they're analyzing data so
i guess you would need to kind of get
some experience in what your subject
matter expertise is and machine learning
it data visualization and work on having
solid communication skills in school
that they're working in the financial
domains and if you yeah if you have a
strong subject matter expertise in in in
finance and you're interested in data
analysis and taking taking data derived
from big data sources and helping us in
decision support helping to advance
businesses then did a scientist sounds
like a good role for you I think you
never come to the end of a questions
thanks a lot for patient you're
answering all the queries to all the
participants or we will be sharing the
recording of this webinar with you so
that you can refer back to it and also
through our give you can get in touch
with it with also the people who had
personalized by you
our carrier consultants reach out to you
thanks a lot religion thanks a lot for
sharing your time with us hope you
benefited from this webinar and you
choose simply learn to partner for your
carrier success going forward to thanks
a lot
you